you know pretty always dreamed of
turning Paisley Park his home into a
museum and now it's finally becoming a
reality
et scored the coveted invitation to
preview his private compound and sit
down with his sister tyka when your
brother passed away what was that like
for you it wasn't hard at all it was a
two-second phone call he's gone I had
been preparing for two years so I knew
that it was coming what does that mean
he said it a couple of years ago what
would he say um what he said was I've
done everything that I've come to do so
I was crushed for about two two years
[Music]
he's not here physically but through
Paisley Park and his music he'll live on
forever Paisley Park Prince's 55,000
square foot mansion of musical
creativity outside of Minneapolis
metropolis he once told Oprah he'd never
leave always leave many of us do you you
will always live here why it's so cold
it keeps the bad people on I believe
that I remember that piano so well it
reminds me of him and see the scuff
marks on top that's from Prince dancing
on the piano and now lovers of Prince
and his music can feel his vibe
firsthand with the Paisley Park
experience a guided tour of the creative
Enclave
Prince once called home studio a is
where much of Prince's music
materialized we have a drum kit set up
ready to start playing and even the
peach drum kit from sign of the times
will be on display the one that he
shared with Sheila yeah
[Music]
even handwritten lyrics on the stand now
what is this we're headed into the world
of Purple Rain my tour guide was archive
director Angie Marchesi
we've got one of these stunt bikes from
the film
the white cloud guitar
and matters the Oscar that's the Oscar
it's unbelievable look at Apollonia
right behind the sunlit atrium is one of
Prince's favorite rooms it's called the
little kitchen this is where Prince
would actually watch basketball Big
Timber will fan of course there are
millions of fans like me who haven't
gotten over Prince's passing last April
tyka spoke to many of the mourners
outside Paisley Park what was on my
heart was two things thank you for
loving him he loved you too and it's
raining outside
you guys are getting wet go home how can
we reconcile this thing it kind of
breaks my heart because there's so many
people that are hurting so I guess I
would say give it another year and a
half and maybe you'll be where I'm at
and so I'm so sorry the charity
it really was a weirdly haunting day
because you expect prints to pop up at
any moment now the one thing you will
not see thankfully during the tour is
the elevator where Prince was found they
were sealing it up as we were there also
the estate will open to the public
tomorrow but only on a temporary basis
as they try to work out permit issues
but you should go see Paisley Park
[Music]
you